Hello, guys. How are
you doing? My name
is Justin Popp.
I'm a third-year
medical student. I'm
a research scholar.
I work with Dr. Rady
Ramos. I've been
doing research with
him since January of
2023, studying
neocortical development.
I'm here to give
you a lecture
today on the
anatomy and the
physiology of the
vestibular system.
It's been a pleasure
to work with him,
and I'm grateful
for this opportunity
and his guidance to
give you this lecture
and to be able to
work with you guys.
I hope you guys
had a good,
restful winter
break, and I hope
you're ready
to get started.
so some objectives
we have in this
lecture are to describe
the anatomy of the
peripheral vestibular
system including
the otolith organs
and the semicircular
canals we're also
going to describe
the anatomy and the
physiology of the
hair cells in the
macula and the cristi
the macula are a
part of the otolith
organs and the
cristi you'll see are
related to the
semicircular canals.
We're also going to
describe the central
vestibular system
anatomy and its
role in postural and
oculomotor control.
And we're also going
to describe some
pathology, some
clinical examples of
vestibular system
disorders, such as BPPV,
or BPPV,
benign positional
proximal
vertigo, along
with others.
So our vestibular
system helps us maintain
posture, balance, eye
movements as we move
our bodies, our heads
in our environment.
When we drive
in cars or go on
planes or ride crazy
roller coasters,
this vestibular system
is pushed. um and
we um a lot of people
take it for granted
how much um physiology
how much action is
going on just to make
sure you don't fall
over when you when
you're walking or uh the
awareness to know
that like when you're
driving in a car you're
staying still but
you're moving very
fast 60 miles per hour
or something, uh,
through, through space.
Um,
so vestibular
dysfunction, uh, could
present with, uh,
vertigo, which is a
sensation of the
world moving when it's
not, as well as
postural instability.
Um, the word vertigo
comes from the, uh,
Latin vertir, uh, which
means to turn. Um,
this could be
helpful to, for you
to deduce what
vertigo actually
means. It's
essentially a spinning
when the world isn't
spinning, right?
So there's some
connection of words there.
Some clinical signs
include nystagmus, which
is a repetitive
uncontrolled eye movements,
as well as a positive
Romberg test, where
you basically have the
person stand with both
eyes open for a little
bit. Then you test
them with their eyes
closed and see if they
fall to either side,
which can detect some
sort of balance issue
that they might have.
And these vestibular
disorders can be
peripheral or central
in their nature.
Peripheral coming
from the ear and the
vestibular ganglion
or structures over
there or centrally
as in the cerebellum.
So let's just admire
the anatomy to start
with. You have the
external ear canal, the
tympanic membrane.
This is the middle ear.
We're not really
looking at that. We're
really more or less
focused on what's going
on in the inner ear
over here. You have
some important structures
here located in
the petrous portion
of the temporal bone.
You have the
semicircular canals.
There's three of
them here with their
respective ampulla at
the base of the canals.
You also have the
utricle and the saccule
here as your otolith
organs. Those are
involved in linear
gravitational awareness,
while the semicircular
canals are more
or less involved in
angular positioning.
um as you can see
here um we'll go over
endolymph in the hair
cells but basically these
electrical signals
get placed onto the
vestibular portion of
cranial nerve 8 and that
essentially hooks up
to bipolar cells which
are the cell bodies
located in the vestibular
ganglion and then
those have projections
to a slew of different
nuclei vestibular
nuclei as well as nuclei
in the cerebellum,
the floccular nodes,
and the nodular node.
So the vestibule, which
is the utricle, the
saccule, and the
semicircular canals, they
are bathed in a potassium
-rich fluid known
as endolymph. And
this is going to be
very important when
we see how our action
potentials are generated
for signal transduction
for our awareness
in our environment.
We also should note
that the endolymph is
in the membranous
labyrinth, and the bony
labyrinth actually
surrounds this membranous
labyrinth. And that
bony labyrinth contains
perilymph, which is
high in sodium, low
in potassium. It's
very similar to
extracellular fluid in
terms of its composition.
So continuing or going
deeper with some of
these organs here,
we see the three
semicircular canals. uh
each um canal corresponds
to a plane of the
body uh we'll get into
that later in this
lecture and at the base
of each semicircular
canal is an ampulla
with a cristae involved
that contains hair
cells and a gelatinous
membrane we'll get
into um that in a
little bit the otolithic
organs The utricle
and the saccule have
something called a
macula, and the macula
contains otoliths, which
are calcium carbonate
crystals on top of
the gelatinous matrix,
and the hair cells of
the macula essentially
stick up into this
gelatinous membrane.
And those signals get
projected onto the
vestibular ganglion.
Notice these are bipolar
neurons. See how there's
axons going from the
ampulla and the macula
going to cell bodies,
and then axons going
away from this ganglion,
the vestibular ganglion
projecting onto
the vestibular nuclei,
amongst other areas.
So now let's go into
the otolith organs.
Like I said before,
the saccule and the
neutral cavity is
filled with endolymph,
and each macula
is filled with
these little hair cells
like I talked about
earlier. So you
see the otoliths on
top. Now, let's pull
back out, right?
This in of itself
is a macula.
On the bottom right
-hand corner picture is
a macula. It's a zoom
-in of a macula, and
this can be in either
a saccule or a utricle.
So a specific macula
is made up of otoliths.
These otoliths are
calcium carbonate
crystals that essentially
lay on top of this
otolithic membrane,
which has a very high
specific gravity and is
gelatinous in nature.
And as you can see,
you have the hair cells
projecting into this
gelatinous matrix.
You may also notice
that there's one really
long cilia and a few
shorter ones. The
shorter ones are
called stereocilia, and
the tall one is called
a kynosilium. And
we're going to see how
this gets important
with the actual
transmission of the
signal. But essentially
what happens is
the movement of this
gelatinous matrix moves
the hair cells in
a specific way, and
that can either
hyperpolarize or depolarize
the cell, and that
will either, if it's
depolarized, result
in action potential
propagation and a
firing of the signal.
So, like I said
before, the utricle and
the saccule, they
encode position and
movement of the head
with respect to gravity.
This is a linear
acceleration. So
what we see here in
the utricle is that
the utricle, the macula
of the utricle is
positioned in such
a way where the hair
cells remain upright,
while in the saccule
you see the macula
are in a position
where the hair cells
are on their side.
so the saccule is
specific for um let's
say up and down
motion like let's say
you're moving not not
in a front and back
direction but more an
up and down direction
as if you're moving
in an elevator these
will specifically
fire however if you're
moving more or less
in a front to back
uh or if you're
moving specifically in
a side to side
motion uh the utricle
will get activated
Um, as you can see,
this motion moving left
to right will cause
the gelatinous matrix
to move and that
will either hyperpolarize
or depolarize
specific populations
of hair cells.
Um,
let's say if
you're moving, um,
let's say you're
driving in a car
and you suddenly
hit the brakes,
both the utricle
and the saccule will
have some activation
there in terms of the
relative motion
that was caused from
you braking on your,
braking your car,
and that caused your
head to move, and it
will cause both
the utricle and the
saccule to essentially
move and activate.
and we'll get
into some of this
neurochemistry with
potassium calcium
and glutamate in
a later slide so
what we see here uh
is some of the actual
chemistry that's
going on here right so
let's say we have a
utricle here for example
it doesn't matter um
what you're seeing
is the kynosilium
and the stereocilium
they're sort of tethered
by what we call tip
links these tip
links are essentially
mechanoreceptors that
can feel the motion of
the gelatinous matrix
moving if the motion
of the gelatinous
matrix is towards the
kynosilium so it's
essentially moving towards
the longest cilia,
the kynosilium, this
will cause potassium
from the endolymph,
the surrounding
fluid, to rush in via
these potassium channels
on the tip links.
As potassium concentration
increases inside
the cell, this creates
a potential difference.
It increases um the
membrane potential
and this causes uh
once you hit or hit the
threshold right this
causes potassium uh
calcium to flood into
the cell the calcium uh
via these calcium
channels here these
calcium channels
are open and this
causes the binding
of glutamate uh this
causes the facilitation
of glutamate
into these uh
vesicles And these
vesicles essentially
exocytose glutamate.
The glutamate goes
to the synaptic cleft
and binds to postsynaptic
receptors, causing
the propagation of
the action potential.
We should also note
that if the hair cells,
the kinocillium, or
if the gelatinous
matrix moves this
kinocillium in the
direction going away
from the kinocillium, as
seen in the bottom
right image, this will
cause hyperpolarization
and less frequency
of action potentials
to be fired. So
I did mention
this earlier with
how these otolith
organs are sensitive
to gravity and
linear motion.
So the utricle is
responsible for this
side-to-side motion,
detecting that
saccule is more or
less responsible
for movement on an
up-and-down plane.
so a lateral horizontal
movement mostly bends
the utricle hairs
while the hair cells in
the saccule remain
mostly unchanged so
remember these hair cells
are essentially stuck
in this gelatinous
matrix when this person
moves himself to the
right on the screen
there is essentially
inertia of the gelatinous
matrix from the motion
of the head. And
this resistance to
motion causes a relative
force that pushes
the hair cells in the
opposite direction of
the motion of the head.
And that's due to
inertia, which is
a principle of
physics we all know.
And that's causing
these hair cells
to essentially
go or move in the
direction opposite
to the head motion.
Now, when you're
moving front
to back, you can
get activation
of both utricles
and saccuals,
and the position of
the hair cells on
the utricle and the
saccual can also
change depending on
your head position.
Like, let's say this
person is lying down
to take a nap or
whatever. um you can
see the possession
relative position
of this head is
changing the way in the
direction that these
head cells lie so
now uh going away
from the otolith
organs now heading
towards more the
semicircular canals
um so basically these
they're three ducts
uh they emerge from
the utricle and
they're each oriented
on three planes uh
on the three major
planes of the body.
You have one going
on the z-plane, which
is the yaw axis. You
have one going on the
x-axis, which is the
roll axis. And you
have one going on the
y-axis, which is the
pitch axis. And this
helps detect angular
head motion along those
three major planes.
And there is an ampulla,
which contains a
cupula, inside of each
semicircular canal.
So to clarify, the
cupula is this gelatinous
matrix, or membrane,
that lays on top of
the hair cells, similar
to the otolith organs
in a way, right? And
this structure, the
cupula and the hair
cells, are located in
the ampulla of the
semicircular canal, and
relative motion of
this cupula can either
hyperpolarize or
depolarize the hair cells,
and that can cause an
actual potential to
propagate. So looking
at the semicircular
canals, you can sort
of just logically think
about what plane is
involved with each of the
semicircular canals
and what motion it sort
of produces. So if you
look at the horizontal
semicircular canal,
that's going to be
responsible for a sort
of nodding your head,
no, type of motion,
as you can see here.
Um,
the posterior, the
posterior semicircular
canal, uh, that would
be more responsible
for, uh, motions
nodding your head, yes.
And what we see here in
the anterior semicircular
canal, that's going
to be responsible
for bending your head
or bringing your ear
towards your shoulder,
that type of motion.
Also, this is an electron
microscope picture
of the cubula.
So let's talk about
sort of what's going
on here, how this
actually happens.
So the crosti, like
we talked about,
that, yeah, the crosti,
which are located
in the ampulla,
those respond to
rotary acceleration.
So during a head
rotation, the head
rotates in one direction,
yet same principle
with inertia.
The endolymph
actually lags behind
and causes a
relative force on the
cupula in a direction
that's opposite
to that of the
angular head motion.
So basically what's
going on here is that
you have head motion
in one direction.
The neuroepithelium,
the semicircular
canal, also moves in
one direction, but
the fluid moves
slower behind it. It's
almost like running
with a cup of coffee
in your hand. You're
moving forward,
but the fluid is going
to spill out behind
you and possibly
get on your shirt.
The backflow of that
endolymph displaces
the cupula in a
direction, as seen in
this image here, and
that could either
cause a hyperpolarization
or a repolarization,
which then will
go on to the
vestibular portion of
cranial nerve gate.
The endolymph doesn't
cross from either
side of the cupula.
The cupula is
sort of attached to
both sides of the
tissue here, of that
neuroepithelium.
So like we said
before, those cristae
respond to rotary
acceleration, and that
endolymph lags behind,
and the endolymph
essentially travels
essentially in a direction
opposite to that of
the head turning and
pushes on the hair cells
in a direction that's
opposite to the
rotation of your head.
Usually, the kynosilium
is lined midline,
and if the endolymph
pushes the cilia
towards the kynosilium,
as seen on the
left here, this causes
depolarization and
the propagation of
an action potential.
While on the
right here, you
see the opposite happens.
The force is pushing
in the opposite
direction of the
kind of cilium
and causing
hyperpolarization and
less action potentials
to be fired.
So now we talked
about what's going on
peripherally and
what's going on within
those major organs,
the otoliths and the
semicircular canals.
Now let's talk about
what's going on for
the pathways and where
all of this stuff
is going to, right?
So there are a
few pathways we're
going to talk about
here. The first
one is vestibular
spinal pathway.
This controls
corrective actions
during movement and helps
maintain balance
and posture.
So let's just
follow this from the
start. We see
fibers from the
cristae of the
semicircle canals as
well as fibers
from the macula.
Those go on to
the bipolar cells
of the vestibular
ganglion in the
internal acoustic
meatus of the
petrous portion of
the temporal bone.
And then these
neurons essentially
fire onto the
vestibular nuclei.
There are a few of
them. There's superior,
medial lateral inferior.
And there are two
vestibular spinal tracts
we're particularly
interested in here.
You have the lateral
and the medial.
Let's start with the
malateral. The lateral
vestibular spinal
tract, basically,
the lateral inferior
vestibular nuclei send
ipsilateral projections
down to the anterior
horn of certain spinal
levels. And this
controls the contraction
of forelimb and hindlimb
muscles to maintain
your balance in an
upright posture. So
let's say you got shoved
or something pushed
you and you had to try
to catch yourself. This
could be responsible
for helping yourself
maintain some balance.
And as you can see,
this red pathway
essentially hits onto
the anterior horn. And
this goes to flexor
and extensor muscles.
Notice that this
is ipsilateral.
muscles that
help with the
stabilization of
your head and neck.
Sterinocleinomastoid
is a big muscle
involved in this and
any damage to this
pathway can cause a
person to not be able
to activate their
sternocleinomastoid.
Next pathway
we have is the
vestibial
cerebellar pathway
and this controls
corrective actions during
movement and also to
help maintain posture.
So as we can see
here, you have
projections from the
vestibular ganglion going
into some deep cerebellar
nuclei like the
vestigial nucleus, as
well as the flocculus
laterally and the
nodule in the center.
Also note that
these are only
ipsilateral
projections as well.
Try to keep that in
mind, ipsilateral or
contralateral for
these pathways. Right.
So another one is the
vestibulothalamic
pathway.
So since this is
going to the cortex,
this is this is
dealing with conscious
perception of your own
body and eye movement
in relation to your
environment. So
this is conscious.
Right. This is not
reflexive. This is
conscious. So this is
something to keep
in mind because it's
going to a central
processor, such as the
somatosensory cortex
in the parietal.
So what we see here
is you have what's not
included is the vestibular
ganglion sending
projections to the lateral
and superior nuclei
at the pontomedullary
junction, as seen
here. And these send
bilateral signals to the
VPN of the thalamus,
the ventral posterior
nucleus of the
thalamus, and then these
send projections to the
vestibular cortex. So
next one is the
vestibular oculopathway.
This controls corrective
eye movements to
maintain posture and
fixation during movement.
This includes
ipsilateral and
contralateral
projections here. So
this helps explain this
a little bit better.
So just going over
just regular eye motion
without the vestibular
system, what we see
here is there's two
types of eye motions.
There can be either
smooth pursuit, such as
your eyes following a
bird or a plane across
the sky, or saccadic,
your eyes jumping
rapidly from one target
to another. These don't
necessarily involve
the vestibular system.
You can do this just
by watching someone's
extra eye muscle
motion by doing like
an H test, watching
their pupils and their
eyes track your hand.
or you could just
put two objects on,
hold two objects in
front of them and
tell them to look from
object to object
without really moving
their head and that
would sort of dictate
how well their saccadic
eye movement is.
So what you're
seeing here is in
coordinated conjugate
lateral gaze.
If you want to look
to the right, what's
going to happen is
the abducens nerve
is going to fire
causing the right eye to
deviate laterally
while the abducens is
going to fire around
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus, causing
the opposite eye
to activate its
medial ******, causing
a deviation of the
left eye inwards,
which will help it
look more to the right.
It's also important
to note that these
voluntary eye
movements, it's
coordinated in area 8
in the frontal cortex,
seen in the top
right corner here.
This area 8 sends
signals to the perimedian
pontine reticular
formation. And
this helps coordinate
this lateral conjugate
gaze that we talked
about earlier.
So this is what I was
mentioning before.
You could test
for saccadic eye
movement. This isn't
really involving the
vestibular system
as there's no motion
of the head or
body. So this is
non-vestibular. This
is just checking
extular ocular eye
motion. You could have,
like I said, two objects,
and you could tell
them to look rapidly
from one to one to see
if saccadic eye
movement's smooth, or you
could move your finger
slowly across their face
to judge how well their
smooth pursuit is.
So when the body is
moving or when the
head is moving,
this is when the
vestibular system
starts to get engaged.
The vestibular, ipsilateral,
and contralateral
projections to
cranial nerve nuclei
that control
eye movement as
well as projections
to the PPRF.
So what that's
basically saying is the
vestibular nuclei is
able to fire on the PPRF
and when you're moving
your head in whatever
direction, the vestibular
nucleus is able
to fire on the PPRF
and the PPRF is then
able to act on the
abducens nerve and causes
your eyes to move
the way they should.
And the way they should
is seen here. So if
this patient, right,
you turn their head,
I guess he's turning
his head to the
right, if you will,
what you would
expect to happen is
that his right eye
is going to adduct
towards midline,
while the left eye
is going to abduct so
basically when you turn
that head to the right
the abducens
nerve on the left
side is getting
activated to cause
lateral deviation
of the eye
while the oculomotor
nerve on the right eye
is causing action of
the medial ****** to
cause that right eye
to draw inwards. And
this is all mediated
by head motion, which
then activates the
vestibular nuclei,
which activates the PPRF,
which then acts upon
the abducens nerve,
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus, and
causing that to occur.
However, if I did
this test and I
didn't see this motion
of the eye and you
saw this reflexive
saccadic motion
back to look at you
to try to correct
it, you would know
that there is a
vestibular dysfunction
in that patient.
So I just want to
put this in here.
Questions can be
asked about some
of these clinical
presentations
that we're going
to go over now.
If you understand
the neuroanatomy
and you keep the
pathways in mind and
you focus on the
big details I try to
harp on, you will
increase your chances
of getting these
questions right.
So let's start with some
of these conditions.
First one is BPPV, benign
paroxysmal positional
vertigo, and
everything's in the name.
So benign, it
doesn't worsen over
time or reflect
additional pathology.
Paroxysmal, it
means it abates
relatively quickly.
The episodes
usually last less
than a minute.
This is positional
as well. It's
elicited by particular
head motions.
And there's a
vertigo. It's usually
a rotary vertigo,
and there's
some nystagmus and
nausea as well.
Most cases are idiopathic,
but there can be
a link to head trauma
or viral infection.
And it's also
common in people who
are auto mechanics
and plummer. They
lay down and position
their body and
head in awkward
positions, and maybe
there is a
relationship there. Um,
and if you think
about it, there could
be, because really
the pathogenesis of
the disease is, uh,
those calcium carbonate
otoliths that lay
atop of the otolithic
membrane essentially
gets, get, uh,
get loose and
fall off. They get
stuck in the
semicircular canals, and
this sort of alters
the natural motion
of the endolymph
as well as the
Christi in those
semicircular canals.
so if you have a
patient that presents
just like such with
uh vertigo dizziness
um that only lasts
a minute when
they're only in
specific positions
uh you would want
to work them up
for bppv and how
would you do that
you would do that
with doing what
we call a ***-Hall
-Pike maneuver.
So essentially what
happens is you tilt.
The patient's
head 45 degrees
towards the
effective side.
And then you rapidly
bring them supine,
as seen in the image,
over the top, over
the table. And then
you hold it there. And
what you're looking
for is if they're in
that position, do
you see in nystagmus?
And if you do,
that's positive, and
this indicates
peripheral vestibular
dysfunction,
possibly from those
loose otoliths
we talked about.
The test is negative.
The vertigo is
more likely due
to dysfunction of
vestibular circuits
in the central nervous
system, which is
a little bit more
worrisome and a little
bit more serious.
So when the ***
-Hallpike is positive,
you can essentially
then treat it with
something called
the Epley maneuver.
The Epley maneuver
attempts to return
those oriconia to
the utricle. There is
a pretty good
success rate in this
procedure, yet there
is a 50% recurrence.
I doubt you guys
are going to
be tested on how
to perform this.
So here's a
general method.
You tilt the head 45
degrees towards the
effective side you bring
them supine directly
over the table the first
part is essentially
the ***** hall pike but
after you bring them
supine you then rotate
their head you wait
30 seconds you then
rotate their head a whole
90 degrees then wait
another 30 seconds
rotate their whole body
another 90 degrees and
then you bring them
upright and you hope
that returns the otolith
back to the utricle.
And it's sort of like
that little game on
the bottom right, where
if you tilt the table
a certain way, you
can get the balls to
go into the hole that
they're supposed to.
It's kind of like a
little game like that.
So next disease is
Meniere's disease.
This is a cause of
peripheral vertigo.
An important note we
see here is that usually
peripheral vertigo is
more severe in terms
of its intensity than
a central vertigo.
Meniere's disease is
caused by improper
endolymph resorption
in the vestibule.
Remember how those
vestibular organs
are covered in
endolymph, which is that
potassium-rich
fluid. So this is
just improper resorption
of that fluid.
This can be idiopathic,
but it can be
viral in nature.
There's something,
there's autoimmunity
involved, genetics,
or the environment
could also be involved.
The symptoms of this
include recurrent
episodes of
peripheral vertigo, as
well as fluctuating
unilateral sensorineural
hearing loss, as
well as a unilateral
tendinous. This is
the Meniere triad.
um these are some
things you should be
focusing on in your
questions how the
patient actually
presents you're going to
get a lot of information
off the history
and your physical
exam on these types
of questions that
could help hone you
into the right answer
treatment includes
antihistamine benzos
and antibiotics the
next disease we have
here is labyrinthitis
it's caused by
inflammation of
the membranous
labyrinth which contains
your endolymph
of the inner ear.
The etiology is
a bacterial or
viral infection.
So this is an
infection leading
to inflammation.
And it could also be
caused by a systemic
autoimmune disease
as well as HIV.
It can cause a severe
vertigo, nausea,
vomiting, tinnitus,
and or hearing loss.
uh the patient usually
makes a full recovery
but some are left
with residual balance
or hearing issues um
so it this can sound a
lot like meniere's but
um one thing i guess
i can say to you guys
is that labyrinthitis
is labyrinthitis is
an infection of the
middle ear of the of
the inner ear i'm sorry
but meniere's is not
necessarily an infection
but it can be caused
by an infection.
While Meniere's is
more likely to present
with multiple recurrent
episodes of vertigo,
well, that's more
unlikely in
labyrinthitis.
Another issue we
have, we could have
here is vertebral
basilar insufficiency.
So as you see
in this diagram,
the two vertebral
arteries essentially
cross the C6
transverse foramen, and
they join up to form
the basilar artery.
And this is caused
by inadequate blood
flow through the
posterior circulation.
The medulla, the
cerebellum, the pons,
the midbrain, the
thalamus, the occipital
cortex can all be
affected in this case.
It may occur as a TIA, a
transient
ischemic attack,
usually caused by
arthrosclerosis
of the vertebral
arteries or
basilar artery. It
can also be caused
by a traveling
embolism as well.
Risk factors include
hypertension, smoking,
older age male,
positive history for
vertebrobasilar
insufficiency in the past,
obesity, diabetes,
and hyperlipidemia.
Symptoms include
a central
vertigo, syncope, nausea,
visual or auditory
disturbances,
dysphagia, or
hemiparesis.
so this is not really
something you should
memorize yet but um
not that you have to
memorize it but it's
really good to like
because you're going
to be doctors you're
going to be ascribing
all different types
of medicines and
really knowing the side
effect profile is
really beneficial for
your patients as you
could warn them about
them or you could
maybe decide not to use
them due to certain
side effects, right?
So these list of drugs
are known to
be autotoxic.
Aminoglycosides,
furosemide, splatin,
quinine, salicylates,
erythromycin, vanco,
and opioids, these
can all be autotoxic.
So another insult to our
vestibular system
can come from a
posterior
circulation ******.
Posterior
circulation strokes
occur, they
count for about 1
out of 5, 20%
of all strokes.
Most of them are
ischemic in nature,
caused by an
arthrosclerosis,
an embolism, or
even a dissection.
These posterior
circulation strokes, this
is simply an order at
which they occur. So
they most commonly
occur in the posterior
cerebral, then after
that, the posterior
inferior cerebellar,
then the superior
cerebellar artery, and
then the anterior inferior
cerebellar artery
is the least common.
But the patient can
present with central
vertigo from
vestibular nucleon
involvement at the
pontomedullary junction.
There could be ataxia
from cerebellar
involvement,
nystagmus vomiting, as
well as headaches
and motor weakness.
Another syndrome
we're going to
talk about here
now is Wallenberg
lateral medullary
syndrome.
It can cause a central
vertigo and it's
caused by an occlusion
of the posterior inferior
cerebellar artery.
So there are a lot of
nuclei in this area
to be aware of um you
have the vestibular
nuclei here at the
pontomedullary junction
uh that is supplied and
these nuclei are supplied
by the pca in part
which is why if there
is an occlusion of
it these nuclei aren't
going to get perfused
they're it's going to
get infarcted essentially
from the occluded
pca and in this case
since the vestibular
nucleus can be damaged
you can get a vertigo
and nystagmus that
occurs beats in the
direction of the gaze.
There could be ataxia
or dysmetria from
the inferior cerebellar
peduncle insult.
And remember that the
inferior cerebellar
peduncle carries
the signals from the
bipolar cells of the
vestibular ganglion
to the cerebellum
and the brainstem.
There could also be
dysphagia, hoarseness,
and dysphonia from
nucleus ambiguous
insult as well. And
there could even be a
Horner syndrome and
hiccups from insulting
sympathetic fibers
in the area as well.
You're also
going to get a
contralateral loss of
pain and temperature
in the trunks
and the limb.
You remember your
spinal thalamic tract
crosses in the
spinal cord, with the
anterior white commissure,
I believe it is.
So that decusation
happens there, which
is why this is
contralateral in nature.
And you could also get
a same side reduced
pain and temperate
sensation of the face.
Now,
we're going into some
tumors that could
occur, specifically
posterior fossa
tumors posterior
fossa is an area of
the skull that's
basically located
between the brainstem
and the cerebellum
um so a common uh
tumor type you should
know about is that
a cran occur in this
area is a vestibular
schwannoma uh these
are benign tumors
that arise from the
schwann cells of
the cranial nerve 8.
So Schwann cells
are basically myelin
-producing cells of the
peripheral nervous system,
and it's a tumor of
those Schwann cells.
The similar schwannomas
can also involve the
7th cranial nerve as
well. So you could
see a concurrent Bell's
palsy along with having
the schwannoma. So
cranial nerve 7 leads
to the stylo mastoid
foramen, And cranial
nerve 8 and 7, they run
very close together.
So vestibular
schwannoma can also
cause cranial
nerve 7 issues.
Another type of
tumor we see here
is the posterior
fossa meningioma.
These arise
from the dural
layer of the
meningial layer.
And in the case
here, what we see
is a right
inferior tentorial
meningioma. So this,
what we see here,
this is the tentorium
cerebelli, this sort
of triangular-shaped
piece of durable
connective tissue that
separates the cerebellum
and the cerebrum,
and the tumor is
essentially growing
off of that meningeal
layer. And it's
projecting downward into
the cerebellum, and
this compression can
cause, and this growth
of this tumor can
cause compression of
the vestibular nuclei,
the follicle nodular
lobe, the cerebellum,
and other vestibular
pathways. So
another insult that
could occur to the
vestibular system is
multiple sclerosis.
Multiple sclerosis is
an autoimmune disease.
Basically, it's
an autoimmune
disease against
oligodendrocytes,
myelin-producing cells of
the central
nervous system.
As you can imagine, if
you damage your myelin,
this demyelination
of the cerebellar and
the vestibular neurons
and their axons can
cause some type of
vestibular dysfunctions.
So here's a little
chart for you guys
to go over, just
separating central
and peripheral
vertigo clinically.
So here are some of
the points of emphasis
that we had throughout
the lecture.
We talked about
vestibular
end-organ anatomy,
sphysiology,
the type of vestibular
nuclei, some of the
pathways, as well as
pathologies we went on.
I thought I would include
a question for you guys.
I didn't find this
from anywhere.
I actually just
thought of this just
before I recorded
this lecture.
So this isn't from
anyone. This is from me.
I tried to make
it somewhat board
style and somewhat
comp related,
something that you
might see on your
tests. So I gave
it my best go.
And I think it's a
pretty medium level
question and we'll
go over it, right?
So a 45-year-old
male presents with
dizziness for the past
month. The patient
also feels he has a
loss of coordination
of limb movements
on the right side of
his body and feels
that he wants to fall
to his right side.
The patient also
finished a course of
aminoglycosides to
treat a pseudomonas
aeruginosa infection.
The patient also
complains of loss of pain
at temperature on
the right side of his
face as well as the
left side of his body.
On exam, the patient
has a horizontal
nystagmus that beats
when the patient
looks to the left
and the right.
What is the most
likely diagnosis?
I'll give you a few
seconds to think
about it. um you can
pause the video if
you would like and
uh the answer's on
the next slide so
try not to look now
so the answer in this
case is uh wallenberg
syndrome i can go
over quickly why um
this isn't bpvv i
didn't tell you anything
about the episodes of
dizziness being well
i didn't really tell
you anything about um
the quality of the
dizziness where did the
episodes come on and
off um did they last
for a minute were
they position i didn't
even really give you
that information so
you could rule that
out right um mca ******
uh i kind of put that
in there as like a
random thing um you're
not going to see
these types of dysfunctions
with an mca ******
If you have an MCA
****** on the right,
on the left, I'm sorry,
on a right-handed
person, you can get
like a Broca's aphasia,
but not really related
to this picture.
A drug-induced
ototoxicity, that's
wrong because
usually you may get
more sensual neural
hearing loss.
I really didn't
tell you this
guy had hearing
loss, right?
um this isn't meniere's
the episode there's
really no uh they're
not episodic um
i didn't really tell
you anything about
the nature of it um
you could also look at
the physical exam
findings to help rule
out that and the same
thing with labyrinthitis
there there isn't
really um an
infection yes he had a
previous infection but
that patient was
treated for it uh and
And there's really
no ear pain.
There's really no ear
pain, and I didn't
give you any physical
exam showing some type
of finding of inflammation
in the inner ear.
So you try to rule out
some of these options,
as well as the
physical exam findings.
It could help
you figure out
that the answer
would be C.
I hope that was a
good explanation.
so that's all i have
for you guys uh it's
been a pleasure working
with you guys i really
hope that this
lecture was useful and
formative um feedback
is everything um i uh
teaching is something
that i would like to get
better at a little bit
each day um so because
it would help me to
help you guys better
and to help you guys
to learn what you need
to learn and to
help you guys become
successful doctors in
the future. I wish all of
you the best of luck
and have a great day.